les transports en commun sont ils assez
sécurisé pour les femmes depuis des mois
un homme avec une couronne en papier une
pancarte kiss me i'm the king
c'est le roi donc c'est pas le chef à
celle des femmes dans les couloirs du
métro parisien malgré plusieurs
signalements par des passagères indignés
aucune action concrète ne peut être mise
en place par la ratp
on va on parlait tout lui regardez vous
a fait un petit reportage là dessus
c'est incroyable voilà c'est une info
qu'on vous donne et vous nous direz si
c'est assez sécurisé au pas regarder le
harcèlement dans le métro ça vous parle
bah oui c'est choquant les femmes ne
savent pas quoi faire dans ces cas là je
me sens pas très à protéger en prenant
métro paris
c'est une histoire pour le moins
surprenante qui agite les utilisateurs
du métro parisien depuis plus d'un an
maintenant et tweets se multiplient pour
dénoncer le comportement d'un voyageur
qui depuis de longs mois harcèlent les
femmes dans les rames et couloirs du
métro
cet individu qui tente de faire des
câlins et d'embrasser les femmes qu'il
croise de force est facilement
identifiable puisqu'il porte sur la tête
une couronne en carton de la marque de
fast food burger king
derrière l'aspect amusant de cette
annonce et de cet accoutrement se cache
en fait un pervers qui officie
majoritairement aux stations châtelet
saint-lazare bastille ou encore
montparnasse malgré de nombreuses
finalement et tweets envoyés à la ratp
les agents ont beaucoup de mal agir car
elles sont obligées de prendre l'homme
sur le fait pour pouvoir le sanctionner
à ce jour aucune victime n'a porté
plainte ce qui rend la tâche des
policiers des agents du réseau encore
plus difficile alors selon vous les
transports en commun sont ils assez
sécurisé pour les femmes alors vous
dites vous êtes vous êtes piqué bien
entendu la première la première chose à
faire c'est d'abord de porter plainte
aux tourments peut pas entamer de
procédure maintenant il faut porter
plainte ce qu'est ce qui expliquait les
jeunes femmes et notamment les jeunes
femmes s'organisent maintenant
effectivement desquels la perçoivent
elles elle twitte et elles disent
attention j'ai vu le fameux type à la
couronne dans sur tel rame de métro à
telle date et l'heure etc
n'y allez pas vous faites attention
prévenait un agent ratp sncf en
l'occurrence là ce qui est compliqué
c'est que quand on les cantons prévient
il arrive le type est évidemment déjà
parti donc c'est quand tu dis il faut
qu'elle qu'ils aillent se porter plainte
c'est compliqué parce que justement ce
n'est que la parole il ya pour l'instant
voilà donc ils sont dans une sorte
d'incapacité
donc si vous avez la possibilité filmer
la limite moi je réponds non dans
l'ensemble c'est bien sécurisé le métro
par les caméras mais par les faits quand
on voit lui qui fut qui fout le bordel
là dans le métro ce petit con là qu'avec
sa couronne équipements de déclin quand
ils demandent des câlins à la limite
c'est pas gênant mais on voit après
qu'il harcèle ses petits demande les
numéros défi
et moi je art c'est chiant parce que
quand tu écoutes la ratp mais il n'a
rien fait alors faut attendre qu'elle se
fasse poignarder pour bouger le mec il
est là il traîne dans le métro tu
travailles pas tu casses toi d'là dégage
du métro laisse le métro pour les gens
qui travaillent qui était courante qui
suit avec ta couronne vador et que tu as
froid qu'il a eu la fève mais c'est fait
on rigole mais pourquoi parce que ça moi
ce qui me dérange c'est vrai comme ce
qui me dérange c'est csu s'est à présent
des masses derrière sur les peines
contre quand après il arrive un drame
comme ça tue les gens ils bougent plus
dans le métro contiennent agression les
maquis reste à dire garneau t'agresser
parce qu'il bouge pas parce qu'il sait
que derrière il y aura rien moi j'ai
pris le métro l'autre soit à 11 heures
du soir je suis gaillard je suis
vaillant il ya trois mecs ils sont venus
s'asseoir à côté de moi j'étais en train
de me dire et si ce n'est comme taper
dessus comme une fille punch de chenu
partie à trois sièges plus loin comme
une super jo je les dis à personne je
vous le dis papa façon tu peux venir
vient en parler si je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'assez connu maintenant
enfin toutes les filles en parle
pourquoi abandonner quand elles le
voient pas être prêt veine quelqu'un à
côté enfin un homme parce que les filles
ont du mal à se défendre c'est normal
mais deux pas de le frapper
vous vous en avez entendu parler de ce
jeu bien sûr j'avais oui j'appelle et
sécurisé moi j'aime bien parce qu'il lui
faudrait sécuriser davantage donc plus
de monde
et si vous prenez le micro régulièrement
le métro régulièrement ce qui est mon
cas il ya de moins en moins de monde qui
contrôle qui intervient et tout donc
vous êtes et sur certaines ni le soir
vous êtes cinq mois il m'arrive d'être
seul et de me dire ben merde alors
qu'est ce que je vous l'avais déjà
régressé toutefois à paris j'avais
personne va rencontrer ici le maître
fois dans le métro
oui personne chaque fois n'est venu
m'aider ou personne gît le nombre de
lits des fêtes il s'est pas fait
merci non laisser tomber mais à savoir
mais ils suivent un peu l'actualité je
paie la pression sur la personne la plus
drôle rue du métro j'ai vu beaucoup de
ce discours était celle des gens qui ont
été beaucoup plus agressifs évidemment
rôle ou et les meufs cérémonie bloquent
le passage en grèce 4 qui se caressent
de tout jusqu'à la métro sont bons lui
mais d'autres avant lui je trouve que
même physiquement au niveau de sa tête
il me fait penser à batz motel le food
en baisse